uh Schmidt I got you something man
ah they didn't have a Jewish star at the
store
so I got you a regular cookie and I made
the star Myself by breaking off the
pieces it's meant to celebrate your
Jewish heritage
what is this the Jewish star I just said
that hey Schmidt just this is so
terrible
you gave me a cookie I gave you a cookie
you gave me a cookie gave you cookie
gave me Cookie got you cooking
you gave me Cookie I got you cookie man
getting cookie guy you Cookie we're even
we're even Schmidt
I mean what do you want from me
what do you watch man
I've been racking my brain all day
I walked around the grocery store man
for 45 minutes
I didn't know what to get you
then I was thinking I was gonna get your
Ramen I think we used to eat but you
probably eat like fancy Ramen now with
like figs in it I don't know man
you love me too much Schmidt
and you picked the wrong guy
and when are you going to get that
through that giant head of yours
I'm just gonna let you down man
are you crying
I'm not crying yeah
you are crying oh my God I'm not crying
guys just drop it I just felt like I did
something nice tomorrow and that's okay
don't say that man because that
you know what I mean Let It Rain Man I
hate the cookies man that's the best I
can do man
what about the turtle
you're the only Turtle I want
you're the turtle man
I knew I was the turtle
yeah man you're the turtle
you guys are the best man I love you
guys I'm sorry sorry man
I'm gonna uh yeah
foreign
[Music]